Hi everyone, in this lesson we're going to look at some primary hotkeys working with
the Material Editor.
From there we're going to go ahead and look at some different ways you can organize even
more using Unreal.
And then we're going to create a parent material and some instance materials and open up some
parameters for editing.
So let's get started.
Here are some primary hotkeys we're going to be mainly working with in this particular
lesson as well as other lessons when it comes to talking about materials.
Now you heard me talk about how the number one key gives us a variable constant.
We have a number two gives us another variable constant.
This gives us color information on this particular one.
And three and four as well as a power node.
There's a reflection vector as well as a texture sample which you saw me also hit the
T key to get a texture sample to come up.
The U key for texture coordinates.
We have a B for Bump Offset node which will go over in other classes.
We have a Normalize node and M for Multiply which you'll see me use quite often in this
series of classes.
And we have a Duplicate.
We have a L for the LURP which we'll talk in more detail about how the LURP works later
on in other classes and a little bit in this one.
And then we also have the Paner as well as the Scalar parameter which is basically a exposed
parameter of a simple variable constant.
The one key.
Alright, let's go and jump into Unreal and I'm going to show you some other things you
can do to organize your scene as well as let's go ahead and make a parent material and then
convert that parent material or I should say create an instance material from it.
Now let's go ahead and jump into Unreal here and take a look at creating our own parent
material.
This is the one we're going to reference.
Now you'll see in our content drawer we have a series of ones that you can also look at
too underneath our intro to materials.
You'll see there's a step one, step two, step three and they just give you the basic structure
or you can simply just open up the one that I'm working with in particular this one and
you can just double click on this material and pull it up and you can follow along as
I work in the scene.
We're going to go ahead and build them out.
I'm going to explain how these systems work as well as show you how to create these things,
comment boxes and to be able to help you organize things a bit better.
First up we want to go in here and build our own material.
So I'm going to go to the content drawer.
You'll see in our class folder we have a folder called in class mat.
In here we can simply just go ahead and make a new material.
So I'm going to go and right click in here as I go and right click I'm going to go up
to material.
There's also another section which allows you to get to the more advanced options for
materials which we get into in other classes.
But for now we're just going to go straight up here right where the material rests and
I'm going to click on that.
I'm going to say M underscore which is a good habit to get into for your prefects and I'm
going to just call this sample parent and you can call it whatever it is.
Just don't call them late for dinner.
I know really bad joke.
So I'm going to go ahead and double click on this guy and we're going to move this over
into my scene and I should say into the view so you can see it.
So let's go ahead and open this up.
Now you can have any texture you want when you're creating your parent material because
you want to expose those textures and swap them out later on.
But for the sample purposes and so that you can follow along we're going to use the same
textures that I am working with so we're going to be using the ones from the wet stone underneath
the mega scans.
So if we go to our content drawer you're going to see mega scans and you're going to see
underneath their surfaces and towards the bottom and I'll pulse my cursor you're going
to see wet stone ground and this is the one we're primarily going to work with.
So I'm going to go ahead and grab the albedo.
You don't need the AO for this example.
We'll grab the over here the normal and the rough and I think that's pretty much all we
need right now.
And if you wanted to we could even do use the AO as metallic and for this example we'll
do that.
We'll we'll grab the AO and we'll use it as a cheap metallic.
This obviously is a metallic surface but we're going to I'm going to show you how to get
that set up properly and how that works in Unreal.
So we'll keep that for now.
Let me go and drag them into our scene and you can simply do this whenever you have a
texture.
So I can pull the textures in from my content drawer.
Whenever you import a texture you can right click and import a texture.
You can even grab any texture which I showed before and you can grab it from say your library.
I'll grab these pictures here and say I want to grab you know like we did before you can
grab this and grab an illustration.
Pull it in here.
You can also do that too.
So just a quick reminder on that.
There's multiple ways to be able to get them into play.
So now let's go ahead and go in here and build out what we need.
But before we get too far into that let me talk to you about organization.
Now whenever you're building out your scenes you want to be able to organize things and
put comments and descriptions where needed.
One way to be able to do that is I can go in here and I'm going to move this normal over
here.
I'm going to highlight him and hit the C key.
And if I want to I can call this normal and typically you would but I can change the color
of this comment box to whatever color I need.
And this particular case will choose blue seems appropriate for normal and we'll hit
OK.
And then now whatever I have in this box is going to come along for the ride.
If I move this box over here next to this texture here is also going to come along for
the ride but is non destructive so I can remove anything at any time and I can also delete
it if I wanted to or change its name.
Pretty cool pretty convenient to be able to work with that.
You can also continually add some more description information here with there's a little dot
dot that shows up at the top and you can say hey Tom.
Save my normal alone and my sandwich can't spell sandwich sandwich a sandwich a sandwich
my burger alone.
So you can put all sorts of notes in there and you'll see it show up in the details here
underneath description.
You can also pin that note so that it actually does not lose or scale down to become a very
hard to read.
You can see it from a distance.
It's actually pretty cool to be able to do this and it's just another added way to keep
things organized.
So let me actually attach a few things in here in unreal and build some stuff out so I can
talk a little bit about the string organization options that you have.
First up we have in our texture here let's actually expose this.
We want to expose this so that when we make a child it is actually it can be seen and
edited after the fact and you want to do that going to convert to parameter.
I'm going to call this one the albedo and again these textures can be anything because
in the parent if you obviously if your UVs are matching or you know its destination
in the parent if we have them exposed later on in the instance we can swap them out to
whatever texture we need for that particular scenario of workflow.
I'm going to keep my finger on the M key.
I'm going to hit multiply.
Now multiply and add I'm going to hit A key and do add each one of these kind of acts
like a Photoshop filter.
They work under the same type of principle where you're adding or you're multiplying
you can do this through an inconstant if you want to number wise or you can also do it
via image.
It allows you to multiply the textures between each other and you also have the add so kind
of layers them on each other also.
And we'll talk a little bit about more about that later in the next class where the difference
between them specifically when it comes to UV layout.
So I'm going to go ahead and hit the four key here.
Those could be the three key to this is basically showing you again this is a for constant vector.
You'll see constant for vector there.
This gives us color information so we can start this out as white that works best with
multiply in this particular case.
And it gives us a nice neutral place to be at we want to convert this to parameters so
it actually can be edited after the fact.
So let's convert that to a parameter and we'll call this albedo tint.
And we're going to pull that execution string to the beach.
And I'm going to pull this albedo to the channel here.
And I'm going to grab this multiply and pull that into the base color.
Now you have some even further ways to keep things organized.
If I select these group of nodes, I can right click in here and you'll see there's an alignment
area underneath the alignment area can align to the top if I wanted to now them kind of
stack on top of each other.
Or you can have it so you can keep things a little more straight.
So if I went in here, I can do alignment and we'll say, Hey, you know what, I want to let's
align to the left.
Let's center this.
Let's straighten connections.
You have all options to be able to do that.
Now we don't really have these guys set up in an extreme of a setup here.
So you'll notice the connections aren't really straightening too much here.
And you can also, like we said before, do reroute nodes.
If you need them, move things around.
This allows you to go in here and you can do whatever you want when it comes to building
your stuff out.
Now I don't use them too often.
Typically I'll use a reroute and I just put things in the right area.
I'll use a name to reroute node, which we talked about, which you can go in here and do so.
And that keeps also things a little bit cleaner as well as collapsing, which we talked about.
But I just wanted to point that out that those options are there to be able to do so.
Well, it looks like I double clicked.
So feel free to actually play with those if you need them.
They can be pretty helpful.
Let's go and build out the rest of our nodes here.
Next up we have metal.
Now again, we're not working with metal, but we're going to add it in here so you can just
see me build the system out.
Remember, metal works out as zero to one.
So if I wanted to, I could simply just plug in Metallic in here.
I could also go in here, right click and say, hey, promote the variable and just have my
metal information driven by numbers.
But specifically when you're working with textures and you want a little more visual
fidelity, high quality, you want to try to plug in metal if you have it in your texture
wise, and then we can create a system to be able to control how much that's coming in.
But again, you can promote variable to any of these.
So I'm going to go here under texture sample.
I'm going to go ahead and create, hit my finger, the M key or multiply that's M key left click.
And I'm going to keep my finger the S key left click.
And this is a constant, a constant with an exposed parameter that makes it so that I
can control values.
So I'm going to call this metal ness intensity.
There we go.
Sweet.
And I'm going to set this to one so it's on.
Now you'll notice off to the right or the left here, we have a default value control,
we have a slide minimum and slide max.
So our slide max can still be set to one.
And typically with metal, it's going to be that because it's a zero one scenario.
We can choose the grouping here.
So let's group this so you can at least get an example of it.
I'm not going to necessarily group all of them going forward.
But for the most part, you're going to see it here in this particular example.
So we're going to say metal group as I say group by type group metal.
And we're going to punch this into the B channel.
And then we're going to punch this RGB execution string to a channel.
And we're going to drag this over to metallic.
Awesome.
Great work so far.
You've built your first connection note, or at least I should say the second.
Now let's go ahead and slap the others together and I'm going to explain some of the workflows
for them.
So the next thing we want is roughness.
Let me pull up this guy here.
And again, we want to convert to parameter.
We're going to call this rough.
We're going to convert this to parameter.
We're called this metal.
I'm going to right clicking convert to parameter metal.
And again, we're doing this so that they're exposed.
And in the children, we can change things as we need.
Now the nice thing about working with roughness and it doesn't quite work the same way with
metal.
I'm not sure why does it.
It's kind of interesting and a little happy accident found a while back.
I can use a multiply for it and I can use a scalar parameter for rough intensity.
And that's the S key if you're not remembering.
And I can drag this rough intensity inside of the B channel.
I'll set this to five with a maximum of five.
And you'll say, well, Sean, how come it's one here, but why is it five here?
Well, the cool thing about the rough here is you can use this multiply to your advantage.
It will actually go in here and make it so that you can have a higher value versus the
metal one, which is strictly kind of stuck between one zero.
Now typically this is also one zero, but in this particular case, when it comes to the
rough, having this multiply gives us a little bit of a luxury.
It's kind of a sneaky trick.
So we go to roughness here.
And notice we got a roughness values in here.
Oh, looks kind of nice, slightly shiny in some areas.
Pretty cool.
Now, finally, we're going to go in here and build out our normal map.
Now the normal map in Unreal, there's a couple ways you can handle this.
And you'll see some of our sample content have the same look and feel.
Sometimes when you're working with a normal map, you may decide that you want to invert
it.
So to be able to have that option, you want to actually work with a thing called a flatten
normal.
This will make it so the normal is at an even plane field and at a zero and a proper zero
area.
Unfortunately, though, the default state of this, if we left it here will be slightly
off.
So it needs a little bit of help the way that our flat numbers made at this time.
In other words, it shuffles from one side to the next and pushes a little bit too much
into the negative in the very beginning.
And what we have to do for a flatness is go in here and type in a minus one.
And I can pull this minus one into my flatness here.
And then I can make a scalar parameter just by pulling the string and we'll just type
in scalar.
And the scalar parameter is going to be our normal control.
And I'm going to set this to a value of five, we'll do a max of five, and then we'll also
make a normal group.
And rough, we can also make a rough group on him with him to is exposed.
I'll do rough.
And then now we grab that flatness normal and put it in here.
Now if you didn't want to do that, say you never wanted to invert your normal, we'll
have that option.
You can simply just do I'm going to duplicate this normal.
Let's actually expose them real quick, convert parameter normal.
We can simply just go in here and do control D for a second with it selected.
It'll appear where my cursor is at.
I can simply just hit the M key and have a normal control do control.
You just can be super lazy here.
And you can have something like this if you want it and simply just plug that into the
normal if you want it to.
I'll actually like having the option to be able to invert my normal if I wanted to.
But this is the more simplistic way to do it.
This is the way you'll see on many of our example content, giving you the option to
be able to invert things if you needed.
So once we've made this, we're now going to go ahead and we're going to go to where it
lives.
Let's hit apply.
Make sure everything updates.
And we're going to right click on it and go to create an instance material.
This instance material here.
Now again, you can leave INST at the suffix or put an MI for material instance.
It's up to you.
But Unreal at the bottom will let you know what it is too.
It's better to keep things organized the way that works for your workflow.
I can now double click on this material instance.
And you now see the exposed parameters.
Now you'll notice I don't have some of these grouped.
And if they not catching the first time, I did hit apply.
So if you do go to the rough, you only will see a rough, but for some reason it didn't
update, just hit save.
And it should update accordingly.
And if it doesn't, just close it out.
Mind it, mind it, no, I don't want to.
But we also want to make sure that these guys also have a parameter.
So let's go ahead and do rough.
That's mainly what's sticking out here awkwardly.
And metal has a group.
Let's put this in the metal group.
There we go.
Elbido doesn't have a group.
Let's give it a group.
And it's always good to group things.
Get in that have as much as possible.
There we go.
And normal.
He doesn't have a group.
Let's put him in a group.
There we go.
And we're good.
Now these guys don't have to be grouped.
You can leave them alone because they don't have that option.
So Unreal understands that these are part of the workflow and knows that these primaries
are the main concern.
So now when I hit save, now when I go to the instance material, you're going to see these
populate accordingly.
There we go.
There's the Elbido.
There's the metal.
There's the normal.
And again, all these can be updated on the fly.
And what I mean by that is like we can lower the normal.
We can increase the normal.
And it doesn't have to recompile a shader.
We can control the tint if you wanted to.
We can do this all on the fly.
Kind of like what I demonstrated to you earlier.
Well that's it with this video.
In the next video, we're going to dive a little bit deeper and play with some animated materials
and processes when working with the material editor.
Thanks again.